hi there everyone
today uh
i
hope you've got the book either in the
electronic form now or hard copy
we go to
if you have the hard copy
page one one six
if you have the electronic copy i'm not
sure if it's been moved but it's iccio
dash osensis versus others
so you can read
um what i've put about
how to hold
why not have open hands or that
i'd like to you to
go to
page
and look at picture number six
where the hand
is different than
picture number five
so picture number five is the
eko standard ikea
but ikiyo can also be
number six
where we take the hand
and i'll be showing this
in a film
but before
um
i release you the film of
the iccio
i want to talk a little bit about body
science
um from the day we we step on the mat we
may be
like a clumsy
person
i remember i was wrong feet wrong arms
everything was wrong
one teacher said
put your right foot forward
and then he said uh
and the other right foot forward tony
obviously i was mirroring
them and my left was forward even though
his words weren't right
perhaps that's when dyslexia comes in
and um copying it's not always the
best thing
okay so body science
there's
a hombu style like you know what is the
the major
aikido out in the world today
and there's a film now on youtube saying
about the sensitivity
and we we need to have this sensitivity
just because we perhaps put the banner
that we're training iwama
we wanna you who used to be called but
this wasn't right to think that there's
a school of iwama aikido so we just say
while a style
it's a very
precise
strong powerful art
and the hongbu style is a much more
flowing art
but it's a much more sensitive art and
we we need to look at this
please look at lots of videos
of course
on youtube now you can see everything
but try to
denote what's good and what's bad in
your opinion because that's all you can
do
i just want to talk about
coming together
so the first technique in the book
buddha osensi
uh demonstrated shomonucci icchio
his distance was a good distance a few
meters away actually from his opponent
who was in the book his son
the
doshu that
was passed on now as well
but
he said i initiate
and he brings his hand up now i want to
just move it there so you can see it
my hand blade is slightly at an angle
so if
you the camera
is
my 12 o'clock
over here would perhaps be an angle
going towards the 2 and 3 o'clock
this thumb would be going more to the
nine o'clock
if i do this and i go 12 o'clock
to
the bottom six o'clock
it's too sharp
if this gets hit then if they're more
powerful
than me it comes back into me
there's ways of doing an atemi as you'll
see in the film where i explain
how you can absorb this
but if you
just stand for me and try this put your
hands down by your sides be relaxed just
bring your arm up and you'll find that
bringing your arm up and then stimulate
the fingers and
stimulate the fingers you'll notice that
this
hand is slightly angled
now if i want to take
their wrist
if i wanted to do open hands like in
humble style
and take them down
this is a much more sensitive style so
you should learn this sensitivity as
well can you control your okay
with open hands
i'm not saying mix the styles up i'm
saying try everything
because what it'll teach you is at a
certain point if your body stays fixed
in the position that you entered in
as you start going down you start to
bring
ook his arm in front of you
so you're actually going to be blocking
your own path
the seat makes a bit of a noise so
excuse that but if you
turn your body
then
they keep to your left in this case
and you still take them down but you've
got a clearer pathway
so it means the sensitivity of your body
the sensitivity of your body needs to
adjust
so this is what i consider is body
science understanding
what you have to do if pressurized
retreat
will retreat to a place of safety and
this is what the
the weapons should be able to teach you
if you study weapons
if it doesn't teach you that and you
just
enjoy doing weapons because you're not
looking at the angles then you're not
looking at the right part of your
training
you should understand when you cut why'd
you step to the left why do you step to
the right
these are
fundament fundamental
uh issues that you you've got to realize
if i put my hand up
i and i now right hand up i should step
to my
left with my back foot
so that the radius of cutting them down
it's not head on i will win this and cut
you down
i step to the right if i bring my left
hand up make the
back leg compass
ascribe
to the right to turn your body this
doesn't need to turn but if you turn
your body then your turn change the
angle with the clash of them in front of
you and if you open up to where there's
a space there here
you're going there where there's no
resistance
once you understand this error becomes
quite an easy technique
where you'll notice in
error icchio
very often
the lower grades you get this blocking
of the arm
it's because you've gone into a place
where their muscle spasm can resist your
your power
okay
so
body science
read the book
on these pages
the
the number six picture is leading us
into our mate
nick yo
but it can be done as you'll see on the
next film series
how it can be icky or nickier
the book does explain everything but if
you see it actually done performed
we can understand how we can make shapes
with our hands
but it's transmitted more
through where our body goes
once our hand meets their wrist
their body
um that is done its job the rest is up
to where you can maneuver
smoothly
and
sensitivity
to the place you need to be
to to execute the complete technique
now on the tatami we we produce the 100
percent of the technique 100 of the
circle
in the street you you might just take
ten percent of that whole technique
and um
but within a flash you'll make your turn
you make this opening down
it's all over
trust me adrenaline is
good but not so good when it encaptures
you as well you don't have time to think
so this is why we need precision
and to me that's iwama style like you
know
uh sensitivity what is honbu style like
you know join them together
to me you've got her senses ikido
thank you for your time